[Music]
ha right you are a lot out too young for
national service but I was in the cadets
we wore the uniform that was that would
have been great for you no class no race
no religion do buri pay attention one in
six Britons never mix with somebody
outside their own class
nearly half of us don't know somebody of
a different race ah Ferrari yes sir
what would a year of National Citizen
Service done for you when you were 16
chubbie I know you won't want this but
let's bribe them let's let's give them
an allowance let's give them a place on
Long Island for all I care but this
would be the making of our young people
don't have to be military if they get
through it at 16 give them the vote if
they refuse they don't get to vote till
they're 21
as you were so just to confirm Trevor
the militaristic authoritarian you are
actually talking about compulsory
national service yes this is me Rachel I
think every young person should have to
play some role in the community I don't
necessarily mean they've got to be in a
trench but they can do something in the
community help old people do something
environment but it has to be mandatory
see I don't I don't understand how you
would look at this nation
sixteen-year-olds and what they're
facing now so if they're at school there
over there over tested if they're not at
school they're underpaid
they're looking at a future with a
climate crisis which we don't show any
sign of dealing with they're looking at
a future where they're not they're not
going to get secure stable employment
you know the chances of them having
precarious employment are high the
chances of them being able to afford
their own home are very very slim so you
look at all the things that young people
will have to deal with in this country
today and that's your solution I just
think that a country that it in
peacetime can find no better task for
its youth than compulsory national
service has really lost its way yeah but
you're missing part of the point of what
young people today are missing they
can't solve the housing problem
tomorrow but what we do know is that too
many of our young people never get to
meet somebody who is not like them never
never meet anybody outside of their
social circle but when we try to do this
this is now 1516 years ago when I
chaired the committee for racial
equality basically what we did is we
took kids from all around the country
away for a summer camp in Cumbria they
loved it because for the first time
we're talking about people in Northeast
they had never met
they had never met a Muslim before that
camp it changed their lives did you
force them to do it no it was voluntary
so that's quite a big difference but we
won't we won't get it to happen unless
every child has this this opportunity
how long for how long would they serve
Trevor well they're people who are now
prompting this are talking about maybe a
couple of months or even six months
Rory Stewart I think has promoted the
idea of several months I think I was
nervous well I was nervous when I saw
all the high profile jobs you know but
when you started because that's what it
was as Rachel it was just the military
but no I think it's I think it's a very
good idea we've got to work out what
they do as regards their GCSEs to their
a-levels these young people but what
absolutely sold it to me so I completely
applaud the idea and I didn't know those
shocking statistics that too many of our
young people don't mix with with
different skin colors or different
faiths and we are speaking at the end of
a week where in London we have seen and
I know this is an unfortunate were a
huge spike in fatal stabbings and other
attacks involving a lot of not print all
but a lot of young people if this gives
them some sense of discipline it has to
be a good idea in Denmark where they
have five year they have a year's beg
your pardon peacetime military service
what the research there showed is it
brought down the likelihood of somebody
being through that committing a crime in
five years after by 43 percent I'm
signing up where do I son you got me I
like the fact that you this crime
statistic you just mentioned I saw that
it does seem to reduce crime where it's
been trialed macrons trying it now in
France he's introducing civic national
service he did start by introducing what
we were all worried about here that you
were
say when you came in the military
uniform makan initially wanted to make
it military service but the Armed Forces
of France said they weren't too happy
with that idea so now it's Civic service
I think you mentioned Rachel climate for
example there could be a way to do this
where for example the young 16 year olds
check what particular national civic
service they'd like if you care about
climate change in the crisis you check a
box that says I'm gonna do something for
the environment in Britain or pollution
and you go to a specific type of civic
service for that if it's for example you
care about for example you're in it in a
city area let's say you're in Tower
Hamlets and you've never been to Cumbria
now growing up that resonated because I
did that in my school took me to Cumbria
for about three or four times and it's a
memory that will never leave me I never
had the opportunity to ride horses I
never had the opportunity to to climb
cliffs or to go through caves and we did
it in the Lake District and we met all
sorts of people and these are memories
that stick with me as some of the
happiest of my life so I think if you're
saying Tower Hamlets there are people
that have never left that bar and
they've never met somebody who for
example is not from the Bangladeshi
background and I think this is really
important that they end up mixing with
people in in other out sort of you know
outer areas and not in a city so you
could pick that one or you could pick
the social care crisis and say that when
you're young maybe you want to look
after people that are suffering from ill
health and at home and need carers well
as a kid I mean my life was bounded by
to tube stations would green and
Turnpike Lane which are less than a mile
apart that was my world
yeah and part of what I think this can
do is open up a new world to young kids
and on the cost issue and the army spent
495 million pounds on a recruitment
drive with an outsourcer which has not
worked they they've basically thrown a
lot of the money away frankly I'd rather
spend a couple of hundred million on
this experience all those adverts no
that was it that was an outsourced
recruitment project delivering even the
most basic of recruitment websites so
that was just a for me yet another
example of public spending wastage but
if I pick up on you I've got a few
points to make sure and my first one out
did I hear you right that you want to
make this mantra mandatory and the
punishment if they refuse is your going
to stop them voting until they're 21
yes and do you think excuse my French
but do you think that no one's gonna
give age if you say mooching around
I didn't verts allow us 30 years of age
if you just said to me you young lady if
you don't do this you're not going to
vote I'd go bothered not you would be
surprised you would be surprised there
are if there is a huge amount of
disengagement amongst young people and
the people that would benefit from the
people you know the programs that you're
talking about it would be and I'm trying
to be stereotypical button unfortunately
I'm probably gonna end up being the kids
that are in these gangs are the kids
that would benefit most i would imagine
from doing a program such as yours
there's kids look whether you like it or
not alright if you say to them mate
listen if you don't go do this you're
not going to vote they will laugh you
out of town have you ever dealt with a
teenager the most the greatest thing you
can do the teenagers say I'm not gonna
let you do such-and-such even if they
never want you to do it before
nobody Michelle not on the voting I
think you know if you want to make
something man mandatory by all means but
come on now I'll get some incentives
that are going to work and then my
second thing is there's this great
program court by the Prince's Trust
called team and it's a 12-week program
and what they do is they put people out
into the community you do a community
project you do a two-week residential
program where you're mixing and doing
activities you do work experience they
help you in English and maths you get a
CV helping and then you get a mentor at
the end of it those programs massively
effective where I think military might
work and again this is me probably being
horrible and stereotypical when I think
about these kids that are getting into
gangs of running around stabbing each
other I would like is part of their
punishment to be dished out to them that
they are forced to go on a program like
you but then I can't with something like
look I mean you know we can talk about
how this is done but the fundamental
point for me is that what we do at the
moment is that once children are free of
school
we basically just completely forget
anything that would make them feel or
compel them to feel part of a community
and have some responsibility to that
community and we just basically spend a
huge amount of money later picking up
the pieces of not having done that to
show you a sentiment but I think you
need to go back to the drawing board on
some of your points in man rights you
may not be willing to admit it but I bet
most of us at some point over the last
three years thought that we could do a
better job than to resume negotiating
brexit well one look definitely on that
one person who thinks that he could have
rolled with it and not looks back in
anger is former a racist frontman Liam
Gallagher earlier this week he tweeted
my name is Liam Gallagher and I've got
four beautiful children and I've dabbled
in drugs over the years I've had many
number ones now send me the keys in
number ten and I'll sort this parlour
out why me why not he then followed up
with par Liam men come on I mean maybe
you could argue Britain's relationship
with poor souls is a lot like a wisss
broken up well Liam we say don't risk
crying your heart out by missing out on
the opportunity to throw your hat in the
ring they'd say only beer
if you won and for that you are a
straight talker of the week that's all
we've got time for this week I'm sure
some of you be pleased don't forget you
can join algebraic just search for the
pledge on Facebook and Twitter and now
you can listen to us on the go with
Apple podcast from lucky things thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]